the known is making its way back to
movie theaters to frighten fans once
again while the demon valik Prevail over
Sister Irene this time and how will it
all connect to the broader Conjuring
universe
on August 24 2022 Warner Brothers
announced some updates to its slate of
upcoming film releases while its most
notable schedule changes concern
tentpole superhero projects an
announcement also included the first
mention of a release date for the nun
too the planned release date for the
horror sequel is September 8 2023 almost
exactly five years after the release of
the first film which came out on
September 7th 2018. while less than five
years will have passed in the film's
timeline here in the real world it's
been a while since a nun solo feature
was released but three other Conjuring
Universe films have come out since then
the curse of La Llorona and Annabelle
comes home both in 2019 and 2021 to
Conjuring the devil made me do it
unsurprisingly most of the plot details
about the nun 2 haven't been made public
but according to the Studio's official
description we know that it will take
place four years after the first film a
priest has been murdered and the evil
behind it is spreading as a result
Sister Irene our hero from the first
movie is returning for Duty after
battling the evil spirit in the original
flick she's a Savvy demonologist this
time around and the only one who's seen
this kind of Carnage before
okay to be scared
scared I'm scared too the film's trailer
promises that those who watch the nun
too will finally discover the truth
behind the greatest evil in The
Conjuring Universe other than that we
don't know much else about the upcoming
sequel Warner Brothers seems to be
keeping the plot strictly Under Wraps
the nuntu is bringing back two key
actors from the first film taisa Farmiga
and Bonnie Aarons formiga who's perhaps
most famous for starring in multiple
seasons of American Horror Story plays
the heroic Sister Irene as for Aarons
who's been in films including Mulholland
Drive and Silver Linings Playbook she'll
be reprising the part of the titular nun
herself also known as the demon valak
Sister Irene won't be the only one
trying to stop Alex reign of evil of
course or Migo will be joined by storm
Reed as another Brave nun hoping to
defeat the demon Reed is an
up-and-coming star who's been a part of
a number of notable projects in recent
years including the Invisible Man
Euphoria and The Last of Us Reed shared
her excitement for the upcoming horror
flick with collider saying the character
I play is incredible I think she really
adds some funkiness to the story and I
love that it is scary but there are so
many character arcs in the film and so
many emotions and Journeys that the
characters have to go through I think it
works perfectly and is something that is
going to turn into a thing that people
really love to watch rounding out the
cast is Anna poppowell from The
Chronicles of Narnia series playing a
widowed mother she'll be joined by
Caitlin Downey of The Princess and Jonas
bloke who plays a character Frenchie who
is possessed by valik at the end of the
first movie
James Juan has become one of the biggest
names in 21st century horror he's a
co-creator of the original Saul
franchise and the Insidious series he's
also the driving creative force behind
The Conjuring Universe Juan directed the
first two Conjuring films and produced
all eight installments in the franchise
up to now receiving story credit for
many of them he continues to guide the
highest grossing horror franchise as one
of its main creative voices Juan is
recently branched out his directorial
outings with DC's Aquaman series and his
original horror film malignant so it
doesn't seem likely that he'll return to
direct another The Conjuring entry but
that doesn't mean that he said goodbye
to the franchise just yet Juan returns
as an executive producer for the nun too
proving that his influence over the
future of the series remains intact
after all what is The Conjuring without
James Wan it's bittersweet for me to
pass the Baton on the first non-film was
directed by corn Hardy but the English
filmmaker won't be returning for the
sequel instead directing duties have
gone to Michael Chavez who's well versed
with the ins and outs of The Conjuring
Universe before helming the nun too
Chavez set in the director's chair for
both the curse of La Llorona and The
Conjuring the devil made me do it it's
clear that producers James Wan and Peter
Safran have great faith in his ability
to bring the scares in an interview with
Screen Rant Chavez spoke highly of his
working relationship with Juan saying
honestly I owe my career to James Juan
I've been a fan of his just like a lot
of you guys to have worked with him on
La Llorona was honestly one of the best
and greatest Thrills the script for the
nun too is coming from the delightfully
Twisted mind of akayla cooper cooper pen
two of the wildest horror films in
recent memory Juan's absolutely Bonkers
malignant and the Blockbuster hit Megan
Cooper told dread Central that she was
especially happy she was able to create
a character for storm read to play
saying bringing more black people into
The Conjuring Universe was a proud
moment
as we mentioned the nun 2 takes place
four years after the first movie which
was set in 1952 so both nun movies occur
somewhere between the events of
Annabelle creation which partially takes
place in 1943 and 1955. the first
Annabelle largely takes place in the
late 1960s and the rest of the horror
franchise generally covers the 1970s and
early 80s as one of the earliest stories
in this horror Universe the nun provides
an interesting backdrop to other
installments the first Conjuring movie
reveals that Frenchy eventually driven
mad by valik later tries to kill his
wife and instead tragically kills
himself take Maurice here it's a French
Canadian farmer had nothing more than a
third grade education yet after he was
possessed spoke some of the best Latin
I'd ever heard given that the nun too
takes place quite a bit before The
Conjuring it may give us more insight
into his internal torment
the first chapter in the nun Saga took
place in Romania shooting on location in
Bucharest in 2017. the horror feature
also spent some time in Transylvania and
director corn Harding had a priest bless
the set just in case any vampire showed
up the nun2 director Michael Chavez has
moved production of the sequel to France
Sister Irene Frenchy and the demon
travel Westward production on the nun 2
began in October 2022 and wrapped just
before the new year with everything shot
on location in France unfortunately
we're in the dark about the exact
locations where production of the nun
too took place and we likely won't know
much more before the film was released
in the fall of 2023
but from what we can tell from the
trailer most of the film looks to take
place within the walls of an Abbey or
convent
while each installment of The Conjuring
series features the same main character
as every Annabelle solo film has focused
on a different cast following the cursed
object rather than its owners it's
possible that the nun could have
followed the lead of Annabelle but the
nun too seems to pursue a more
traditional sequel format with many cast
members returning for the second film at
the end of The Nun Sister Irene used the
literal blood of Christ to defeat and to
power the demon who escaped by secretly
possessing Frenchy in the Final Act
while this ultimately leads to Future
confrontations between valik and the
Warrens the nun too addresses what valik
is up to in the interim and also follows
what happens to poor Sister Irene
the Demonic none known as valik is a
fallen angel who was summoned through a
rift in Romania during the Dark Ages
recognizing the threat Catholic Knights
sealed valak beneath Saint cartho's
Monastery with the blood of Christ
keeping the demon at Bay for hundreds of
years but all that changed during World
War II and the Abbey was bombed and the
seal was broken Malik kills all the nuns
in the Abbey and eventually sets its
sights on Sister Irene though we don't
know what will happen in the nun too we
know that the titular demon survives
through Frenchy using him to inflict
Lorraine Warren with a vision of her
husband Ed's death from there of Alec is
a catalyst for the events of the first
Conjuring and The Conjuring 2 where it
reveals itself physically once again
taking the form of the trademark none a
demon with a similar name spelled with a
c instead of a k is described in a
number of grimoires including the Lesser
key of Solomon with the power to control
all sorts of serpents valak is known as
a president of demons with somewhere
between 30 to 38 Legions under his
control
the main Heroes of The Conjuring
franchise Ed and Lorraine Warren are
demonologists employed by the Catholic
Church based on two real-life paranormal
investigators whose claims have been
widely criticized Patrick Wilson and
Biro farmiga's fictitious versions of
the Warrens are considered two of the
greatest horror protagonists of the big
screen
wackos but we prefer to be known simply
as Ed and Lorraine Warren the Warrens
briefly appeared in the nun connecting
the ending to the first Conjuring but
there's been no confirmation that the
return for the second installment it's
entirely possible that the film could
Flash Forward once more revealing
something new about balik's appearance
in The Conjuring 2. given that the first
film reused the scene from the first
installment the sequel could easily pull
one from the second there's also the
matter of Lorraine's vision of Ed's
death which happened in the first
Conjuring movie in The Conjuring 2 it's
revealed that valik is the demon
responsible and the creature soon hunts
the Warrens and hogson family it's
unclear why exactly valak has the
specific interest in Ed Lorraine so
maybe the nun too will provide some
further answers even if we know that
Lorraine defeats the demon and saves her
husband in the end
every new chapter of The Conjuring
reveals some Twisted truths about the
world whether they're dark family
secrets hidden sins or the existence of
Otherworldly beings each installment has
us coming back for more after three
Conjuring and Annabelle movies the nun
and the Loosely connected the curse of
La Llorona you might think that the nun
too wouldn't have much more to offer but
we're hopeful that it will lead to Fresh
insights previous installments including
Annabelle creation which teased valak's
first solo film have planted seeds for
the next spin-offs or sequels Annabelle
comes home Did It For The Conjuring the
devil made me do it even Tony amendola's
father Perez from the first Annabelle
reappeared in the curse of La Llorona
with that in mind it's entirely possible
that the nun too could have a similar
impact on the forthcoming Conjuring last
rites if nothing else it's likely to
give fans more insight into the true
threat to valik and could even tease a
possible return in the future
for a long time it looked as if the
conjuring franchise was ripe with
spin-off potential not only did Malik
the demon nun find new life outside of
The Conjuring 2 with the possessed doll
Annabelle inspired three features the
Crooked Man was long rumored to follow
but unfortunately producer James Wan
confirmed in 2022 that the Crooked Man
is no longer happening so we don't know
why it's certainly not because other
spin-off attempts have done poorly
2018's the nun is currently the highest
grossing installment to the franchise so
far no future spin-offs have been
announced Only The Conjuring last rites
is confirmed to be going forward meaning
that the Cinematic Universe of The
Conjuring could very well end with its
upcoming 10th installment however that
seems unlikely given the success of the
franchise thus far whatever happens to
the Warrens and their demons next may be
a mystery but there's no denying the
staying power of The Conjuring
foreign
[Music]